christie regarde moi je veux que tu te
souviennes d'une chose parce que souvent
quand les gens deviennent riches ils se
mettent à penser autrement
nous on a réussi grâce au travail à la
patience et à l'humilité
alors je veux te dire de ne jamais rien
attendre des autres il ne te doivent
rien personne ne te feras jamais de
cadeau j'étais toujours première au
lycée j'ai intégré une fac prestigieuse
je reste ici parce que mes parents ont
divorcé
tu sais ce que tu étais rite eu une
fuite de gaz au bois rien on sent rien
mais tu es en train de nous tuer tous
tes rêves vont devoir attend que tu nous
as des manières de vivre
spell très peu poussée qui tu fais
jamais de san avocate il vient aux chats
n'aiment pas que moi plus parce que
c'est vraiment le moment de parler de ça
je crois que l'extraordinaire côtoient
l'ordinaire tous les jours j'ai de
vraies ambitions mais de vraies idées
johnny n'a jamais dirigé une boîte de sa
vie c'est ma faute j'ai sans doute fait
croire qu'elle était plus d'une ménagère
au chômage
je ne veux pas finir comme
il faut que je gère les choses moi-même
une fois pour toutes que bon vent et
bonne chance on y va quand tu grandis et
que tu découvres le monde et tout ce
qu'il contient
l'argent le crime la trahison
on dirait que vous nous racketter dans
l'émoi plus je ne peux pas j'avais de la
vie tu te rends compte que la seule
chose que tu auras
ce que tu gagnes vous êtes dans une
pièce et il ya une arme sur la table la
seule autre personne présente dans la
pièce est un concurrent
il n'y a pas de place pour deux c'est
lui ou faux est ce que vous prenez cette
arme
joy je prends cette arme
écoute - pierre
on ne parle plus jamais de ma boîte à ma
place à l'avenir
d'accord l'homme laddh sa malle
au real